you know you know i had i had a moment
like that as well um i did actually you
know this strip club video that just
came out recently i think by the time
this thing came out it's old news but uh
i i did a video right the strip club
and i i i did this thing and like none
of them spoke english and a lot of and i
was filming with caho but i was
backstage with these dudes a lot of the
time yeah and i had to just communicate
with them in like really broken japanese
and sakura wasn't there to help me and
so yeah seems going well i mean you know
we were there for like a whole like four
or five hours filming and like
so there's like six dances and like in
the last 30 minutes one of the dancers
and like the most american ass accent
was like oh yeah i'm having fun man
and i was like i've been speaking you in
the shittest japanese i i told him like
why didn't you [ __ ] tell me you could
speak english he was like i don't know i
was just having a good time
he's like he's like yeah i don't know i
just uh
think you i think there's an issue and i
was like i was like asking you all for
help i'm like what the [ __ ] is happening
because i didn't know what was happening
yeah because they only told me like two
dances and the rest of the time i didn't
know what the [ __ ] was happening yeah
well i was like
and they were like just go go go go go
gyrate
instagram
very nice guys such good english then he
lived in like ohio for a long time this
guy was like like like his body looked
like a like a greek like form it was
amazing he was just like yeah i just
loved america the gyms were awesome yeah
and i was like see like i i i used to
love doing that but the opposite yeah
when i was like with around with my
friends and like you know of course i'd
be the [ __ ] token tourist guide of
japan right yeah so i'd be like taking
my friends and then just some days i'm
just like you know what i'm i'm going to
be one of you
and just not speak a word of japanese
wherever i go so like i remember
i was taking one of my australian
friends and he was like oh i'll
introduce you to my japanese friend and
i'm like you have another japanese
friend why are you getting me to [ __ ]
talk
so anyway i met this girl
and you know she starts speaking in
japanese and i'm just like i'm gonna see
how far i can take this
and i just and i was just like hey
what's up and just start speaking to her
in english and she's and she can't speak
english or not very well right so she's
like talking to me in broken english the
entire day i don't speak a word of
japanese to her
until the very end you oh my god you're
cruel
that poor girl must have been like [ __ ]
i don't know what to talk to i was just
like mid-conversation and i'm just like
yeah so that was really good and then
japanese i'm like so anyway uh
i can speak japanese
and the look on her face like you would
have thought she saw like the face of
god she's just like
what the [ __ ]
this is like the [ __ ] video where
like a celebrity will wear like a
disguise and go out into the public and
be like yo i was cristiano ronaldo this
entire time or something like that you
know no one asked
i don't troll often but that was the one
time i trolled and it was the best
feeling in my life so i can definitely
see what people troll now do you ever
hear people like talking [ __ ] in
japanese all the time of course uh like
uh when i was doing that quite a lot
yeah when i was when i was little i
remember when i was little like maybe
like ten nine years old and i was in a
supermarket with my sister yeah yeah
yeah yeah i think i haven't have i told
this one yeah you have yeah yeah yeah
but basically i was like picking snacks
with my sister and these like [ __ ]
you know little [ __ ]
just like being like look at those
phones
and then my sister and i heard that and
we just looked at each other like let's
get them
and then we just start speaking in
perfect japanese and the kids are just
like oh [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] out here this
is like balled out i'm like yeah that's
right
get out of here get out of here i don't
know why this has happened but i've
walked into bars like very small bars
that sit like four or five people
numerous times and i'll literally like
sit down and someone like like that
close to me we're like oh gaijin this
yeah like gaijin and i'll be like what
what
i know what that is i'm like i'm like
why would you say that like who says
that yeah you were like does this people
do this in america like oh foreign
is it the same in korea whenever you go
to korea where
whenever there is like a lot of a big
group of foreigners that come in a bar
or an establishment
people notice them because it's the same
in thailand
where we have like a word for foreigners
as well uh what's the word
yeah do you just say it huh then like do
thai people just like say it if there's
like a foreigner next to them i guess so
i mean that's that's how we refer to
foreigners there it's just like oh
you know it's right it's it's like like
even like if you're a foreigner living
in thailand you know the word for long
because because you refer to yourself
you refer you
the few times i've been to korea and
from what i've seen
it didn't really it doesn't really seem
to be that much of a reaction right
sometimes they can tell when i'm
checking out they can before i even say
anything they can tell that i'm not from
there yeah and they'll just like it's
not like uh like oh my god they're just
like oh okay you want a receipt
i guess to be fair like english is a lot
more commonly spoken in korea than it is
in like a lot of asian countries right
oh it is i think so i have no idea yeah
like i'm pretty sure like i remember i
saw this like youtube video ages ago
where this like
you know clearly foreign looking like
child actor who is perfectly flawed in
korean what they did like it was like a
social experiment you know when that
when that was a thing and it was like if
the kid the foreign looking kid only
spoke in english then will korean people
like stop to help out and there was like
a surprising amount of people maybe in
like the big cities who spoke english i
think yeah i think people in korea
aren't really that surprised especially
if it's in like so yeah like because
i've noticed that like when i walk with
my mom and i'm speaking in english
nobody gives a [ __ ] they're just like oh
okay they're not like oh gosh yeah
i've noticed that like in japan i just
like say something i remember i was on
the phone and i was talking to didis
yeah uh because he had gotten to the
studio before me and i was telling him
like i'm on my way yeah yeah everyone
that walked by the double take right
like
it's because you it's because you're
it's because you're an asian woman
though so they just expect
for you to be speaking in japanese right
now maybe because if you were white then
they wouldn't [ __ ] bat an eye yeah
but because you look just like trading
stocks or something if you're white on
the phone
sell my entire stock yeah but because
because you look asian right they're
just like oh wait how why is she not
speaking in japanese that's [ __ ]
weird let's do a double take that's
probably what it is yeah because he gets
the exact same thing yeah yeah
i remember we went on the trip recently
and like whenever because we went to
some towns and cities that weren't like
so big or well known for tourists like
every time we'd uh every time we'd walk
in we'd have to be like yo who's the
most japanese person out of our group
joey i guess you're the most japanese
person you want to hit them with them
yeah
you're like jerry can you go in first
i was like
they can speak japanese but you're the
most japanese looking person you got to
go in because right after you secure the
table then
the clown the clown car foreign
they're gonna expect four other japanese
guys
meanwhile foreigners just being like all
right cool we got it you can't kick us
out now i remember that one
you secured the table and we walked in
and it was like that scene in a cowboy
movie where you walk into the barn the
entire bar just shuts up and looks at
you that was what it was like when we
just walked in i i i could see the look
on the guy's face because like he
because there's this crucial moment if
if all of you are foreign and they walk
in where they're like they're like
contemplating whether it's worth it
to like to be like ah
and yeah we came in and you could look
that he was like oh
yeah he has that facebook like i've made
a terrible yeah literally like it was
clearly like a local like uh yakitori
place right yeah yeah and then like one
of the only eighties
yeah so there was just enough room on
this one table for all of us and there
was like maybe like three groups of two
and they literally all just stopped
eating and turned around yeah yeah i
just like looked at us
there's one person that can speak it
shouldn't that be like okay good there's
at least one person that it's not about
speaking it's about like
being playing the part yeah you've got
to like
fit what they expect yeah
yeah because japanese people uh
don't like something outside of their
comfort zone yeah it's not it sounds
like discrimination and like and racism
and stuff it's not it's not that it's
that they're so worried that they're not
gonna be able to like help you yeah like
serve you that like if you just go in
with someone who kind of puts them at
ease yeah it sounds so so stupid but it
makes the whole process just way easier
yeah and it's not that like i'm not like
i don't want to go in
because i'm like oh no i'm scared it's
like no i just i want to make sure we
can all eat and it's like it's a pain in
the ass yeah just go in get it done
we'll be chill yeah
you know if there's two of us i don't
give a [ __ ] two people they don't care
yeah but like when there's a lot of you
and a lot of foreigners they think okay
maybe they're gonna be loud maybe
they're all not gonna understand they're
gonna be rowdy
hokkaido yeah place where everyone was
like oh yeah dude we were in like the
middle of nowhere in hokkaido yeah and
then like
like this whole bar was clearly like a
local bar because there was only like
three bars in this whole yeah like
100 kilometer radius yeah and we walked
in and literally the entire time people
were just like eating their food like
like that's out of the order every time
someone walked in they'd be like hot
okay
[Music]
they phoned the entire village to be
like yo you'll never get it just came
out to come check this out
but then the moment i started talking to
potential in japanese they were like oh
yeah he was he was super chill like the
guy
the guy running the ball was like
whatever but like it's the customers who
walked in like whoa yeah
this is a place where foreigners would
never go to be fair like there's no
reason you would ever be there as a most
japanese people wouldn't have ever seen
for some of those people i bet
yeah we're like probably
in that part of town at least it's a
place most japanese people probably
wouldn't go as well because it was weird
it was very very it was literally like
three four hours drive from like
a like a town like a big town
so it's pretty far out there and the
detention when we paid he was like ah
it's this mark uh divide by four i trust
you do the calculation yeah yeah
yeah clearly like a community-driven
like little place right yeah yeah i mean
it was cool but like yeah it was cool i
was just going to say that longer to be
fair
for a lot of you know those japanese
people they're like you know connor's
probably the first white person they've
seen like in the flesh influence
sometimes it's flattering because you're
like you're like oh maybe they're
checking me out or maybe they're just
staring at me because they don't know
what the [ __ ] i am
it's like but i can pretend like it's
the first and then i'm like i must be
just so attractive that they can't stop
staring at me
i don't think it's that no i'm sure
they're looking at you like a rare
animal
i'm like whoa
that's kind of cool it's like a shiny
worm pole in pokemon it's like wow
don't really want to put you in my team
but wow yeah that is that is something
yeah i don't know it's really i don't
know sometimes it's chill sometimes it's
flattering because
it's fun and it's annoying it depends on
the mood how tired you are exactly right
you can like learn to embrace it yeah
yeah yeah i i'd say like 90 percent of
the time like if they don't actively
like
kick us out or say no or like cause any
issues i don't give a [ __ ] if they stay
i'm like whatever it's chill i get it i
would stare too yeah like if we were in
the middle of nowhere in [ __ ] wales
and like some japanese people walked in
i'm like whoa
what are you guys doing here yeah yeah
definitely are you lost yeah
i'm like do you need do you need help
like
tokyo is that way
this isn't london
we're a long way from texas